[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
is the tony michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not liberty you [ __ ] eating
[ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the tony michaels podcast and
this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
good good good friday morning
we have a very very very special show
for you today
that everyone's been looking forward to
a story
that most have been getting wrong
as you know
we have
see look see i guess i just can't handle
it i guess
[Laughter]
oh well we have a great great great
interview for you today uh tasha adams
and her son dakota are gonna talk about
stuart rhodes eye patch and the real
story
of how he shot himself in the face it's
right here on the tony michaels podcast
you are not going to want to miss this
we are going to we're going to play this
interview in the first hour and then
obviously we're going to do the bone
hint of the week as well everyone's here
um and caitlyn said what's up [ __ ]
army
uh everyone's saying good morning good
morning good morning good morning robin
good morning yoda
howdy howdy howdy thanks for being here
mj said thanks heaven it's friday and we
got a special show for you today on
friday
we're gonna wait for some more people to
join here
uh gabe is gonna join us to throw into
this interview i think uh if we can get
him on here this is a really really
important interview
uh
there's more than just the shooting in
the face story that's in this interview
uh there's a lot more
they talk about the relationship that he
that stuart has with alex jones which i
think is significant the january 6th we
also we also talked about uh the bundy
ranch and how the significance of the
bundy ranch may have played into the
january 6 uh seditious conspiracy
and the events that happened at the
bundy ranch we also we also asked
several things about the oath keepers
and the forming of it
and i i really think that it's
significant with the forming of the oath
keepers uh a lot of people don't know
certain things about it and you would be
surprised about how stuart actually
viewed the oath keepers throughout the
years
and some of the leadership and and
things that he did throughout the years
that i i think really would take you by
surprise we have gabe here dave don't
don't you agree with the um
it's going to be surprising about the
oath keepers and some of the things that
they said about not only the forming of
it but like
like what its mission was
right yeah that was one thing that i did
not expect was the fact that like how
the you know
people can like because like conception
or their ideas of how it was formed
under this idea that it was like
anti-obama it i did it you know that's
what i had heard and then i got
clarification right during the interview
from tasha and dakota but yeah there's a
lot of stuff in there's a lot of nuggets
in here that they break down that you
know what you might have thought it was
you know everything from the formation
to the eye to even beyond that you know
um that aren't what we all thought it
was right well the other the other um
thing that they talk about in the
interview which has kind of been a
salacious thing i guess is um not only
the the tunnels being dug but who dug
them right you're gonna find out who dug
them um some of them were doug you know
there's the backhoe
talk that the backhoes were in the um
uh in the backyard digging these tunnels
also uh someone reveals about pickaxes
even in this yeah and where they were
dug the other the other thing was like
unregistered guns unregistered vehicles
right in a logging mill area right it's
all kinds of stuff right and this is
it's not even it's not even the uh
uh the fact that it was just like one
time he did it at multiple homes that
they were at right well i like like this
is a pattern
um that they have and i think what what
do they call it like like um um tunnel
tunnel or uh
spikes spider tunnel no no no no no no
the the the this idea of the
oh right it was the idea that they were
escaped tunnels so it's like if anything
went to [ __ ] that he could just like
crawl his way out right tunnel mentality
maybe that's right yeah interview yeah
dakota dakota uh comments on that
specifically that i think what you're
talking about right yeah yeah um
yeah
well and and i think i think the other
significance
of this interview is stewart's
background like like how he thinks
because these people have been around
him for years and years and years so
like they understand
how he thinks what he says
why he says what he says
and how he comes up with these things
right right yeah and it's uh
you know they talk about you know what
it like pre-bundy ranch post bundy ranch
right and like that's how i think that
that kind of like how his mind
changed
you know
um because they definitely br they they
talk about how you know he was a
different person after bundy ranch you
know
um and now that
how that went
to [ __ ] and it changed him completely uh
but also the fact that you know they
were real details about like you know
his uh his feelings toward
uh trump before
or like when he was elected versus after
when he was you know after he was
elected and then also um
just the
kind of overall sentiment to like you
know
what he did and why he felt he had to do
what he did
right well i i think i think we
shouldn't waste too much more time yeah
we should definitely get to the
interview here because uh just just to
let the audience know cause i know it's
friday so we're gonna do bonehead of the
week um so so see me in the in the
private chat there gabe about bonehead
of the week but we're going we're going
to we're going to do bonehead of the
week after the interview airs um it's
about an hour and 15 hours and 16
minutes um with the commercials and
everything i think it ends up being
about an hour and 20.
and because it's so long we still didn't
get to all the things that we wanted to
cover um so we're hoping to have dakota
back on tasha back on to talk about some
of these things uh specifically my
interest is like the bundy ranch thing
oh yeah for sure like they we we only
got a little snippet of that you know
and i included a couple photos of the
reference that we made in the in the
show
but uh
but yeah i would love to know more
exactly about how all that went down
right well and by the way uh for you
people listening and
watching out there um gabe worked all
week on this interview he did a great
job i actually watched the interview
last night um how he cut it so thanks
for all your hard work this week on
getting this done and all the new
graphics everyone likes the new banners
the new graphics centers yeah banners so
uh go go give gabe some love over on
twitter follow him i am gabe sanchez on
twitter and follow
at tony michael's pod because uh you're
not gonna want to miss the bonehead of
the week in the bonehead of the week
polls but also you don't want to miss
any of the episodes so subscribe here on
youtube
uh twitter twitch all those kind of
places so stick around right after this
break
right after this break the interview
with tasha and dakota adams
and the story that everyone wants to
know the real story of how stuart rhodes
shot his eye out right after this
[Music]
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
drupists mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today drew be the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show thank you for
joining us we have a special guest and
her son here today
tasha adams you will know her
as the future ex-wife of stuart rhodes
one of the people
indicted in a federal court
by a federal grand jury for seditious
conspiracy for the acts on january 6
at the capitol
tasha how are you well doing better now
that stuart is
in jail so so that uh bringing that up i
just read some news within the last hour
we are recording this um that his
lawyers are trying to get keep him
detained in texas as opposed to going to
dc they claim which will probably uh
make that claim will probably be made
and held that it will be easy for them
to prepare for his case i believe the
date set for his trial right now is june
11th i'm sure that will change with any
superseding indictments that would come
is that your understanding from what
you're reading about that
yeah i don't think that'll happen i
think i think almost everyone has tried
to
avoid going to dc because of the jury
pool
well so so uh
the reporting that i read that there was
50 that are detained right now in the dc
jail now rather um he gets detained
there or not now also the other news
that i read from um what their argument
was for him not to be detained at all
was that
uh
they wanted to
because he's he's trying to testify and
cooperate with the january 6th select
committee is that your understanding
the crux of
it was
let me introduce you this is this this
is sasha's son dakota um dakota's
joining us as well because he knows some
things about the militia group and the
oath keepers so go ahead dakota tell us
tell us what you know i was a teenage
sidekick on many uh militia adventures
that stewart went on a lot of his trip
so i got an inside view there and uh mom
knows a bunch of stuff that i do not
like the crux of
his i don't need to be detained argument
they carried out a special exception for
him to
travel
to dc to testify before the january 6
committee in compliance with the
subpoena but before that he was
basically arguing that he is not a
flight risk and should not have to be
detained because it would be against his
personal honor and belief system well
well you know in terms of his bail so
basically his argument is i'm a
highlander so you can take me at my word
well is this there can only be one right
one
so so let me ask you is this part of the
sovereign citizen
um thing it was was steward ever a
sovereign citizen or um are part of like
preppers because there was some news the
other day about tunnels being dug and
when i seen some of the video and
pictures i was like this seems like a
prepper thing was an oath keeper thing
ever like a like a pre-dating some of
this um seditious stuff was it ever like
was it ever kind of like this prepper
thing this prepper culture so you take
this and then uh you take sovereign
citizens
and then we'll talk about escape tunnels
definitely um definitely a prepper that
goes without saying everything about his
life he was terrible prepper but but uh
but it was his self-identity nonetheless
he i mean
you just look at his preps and think if
the world ends
and all we have is rifles and tons of
wheat but no wheat grinder
this is not
it's perhaps where i mean i grew up
mormon
we had we had preps but it wasn't a
self-identity it was just stuff in the
basement that meant we didn't have to go
to the store all the time right canned
goods things like that yeah it was just
stuff like stuff you use all the time
and this uh you know nobody wants to go
store use the crap in the basement
that's how i remember it being and our
preps as a kid were better than anything
i mean he was spend lavishly but none of
it made any sense it was just basically
what he wanted to spend money on but
there was definitely an identity with
the prepper
community almost everyone he brought in
he would lecture people and how why they
needed to do all these things and they
needed to have a ham license and they
need he didn't have him lenses but but
you know he would just lecture people on
that type of thing he was not
he took a lot of pride in not being a
sovereign citizen though there was
extreme overlap and cyber citizen is too
complicated for me so you do the thing
the sovereign citizen movement
view themselves they're
even though they're completely insane
they view themselves as the natural
conclusion
of being an american patriot and a
libertarian because they believe that
really caring about the constitution and
our country will inevitably lead you to
believing that our government is
secretly run by
um a private corporation owned and
operated by the queen of england with
the pope as the cio
and
that
you know you know the realistic type
stuff
obscure legal codes and uh
maritime salvage law and tribunals meant
for dealing with uh piracy in the 1700s
those are magic and if you use them
against the new world order there's
nothing they can do to stop you but
sovereign citizens seeing themselves as
this and as having the only truth and
like all zealots they think that the
truth is obvious and self-evident
and everybody who is against it either
just needs a little bit of convincing to
see the light or they're evil
they would try to get their hooks into
oath keepers non-stop they saw oath
keepers relative popularity especially
in the movement and some mainstream
exposure
and they thought we need to get a hold
of oath keepers so we can signal boost
off of it and there would be sovereign
citizen types who were always around
and uh stewart would make use of them if
they had like useful skills like he
would uh
like use them for rides to and from
events
and basically use them as personal uber
or uh
so he had like his own little carpool
going on yeah or to hook him and hook
him up with equipment especially like a
lot of overlap with especially like
locally with radio guys yeah and
sovereign citizens the ham radio
community a lot of sovereign citizens in
that so let me ask you so how did the
oath keepers thing actually start where
did this come from because because it
was was it his mastermind or was this an
idea that someone else cooked up and he
kind of launched or where did that come
from he had basically after law school
and this is hard to imagine after going
through yale law school he had basically
been fired from everywhere because he
has no work ethic i mean when you're an
attorney
you're actually supposed to work you
know you're not supposed to show up
at the law firm at 10 o'clock in the
morning every morning and you leave at
five you're supposed to get your work
done and
he didn't
he didn't and he'd been fired over and
over again we were moving every year and
he kept saying i'm thinking about
starting a non-profit which i thought
was sounded disastrous because to me
that non-profit does not sound good we
already almost couldn't make rent even
though he you know just sacrificed my
whole life to get him through school you
know this is finally he's oh now he can
hold a chuck and then he's just getting
fired
so when he said he wanted to do that i
didn't realize
then but i know in retrospect he was
very involved in the ron paul movement
in nevada um you know ron paul the
movement in nevada was huge
so you guys were so you guys were living
in nevada at this time when he started
the oath keepers we had been back and i
mean we just moved every year
um but yeah we were from las vegas um
and he went to unlv and after law school
and moving to montana and moving around
in arizona and then we were back in las
vegas to take care of his mother who he
hated i don't know it was just we just
had to move it was trying to move
because he got fired again and um was
about to be fired
and um
so i think what happened is he saw the
energy
and the money and the attention and the
and all the people who were willing to
put their time into
the ron paul movement and he thought oh
how do i absorb that for myself and so
you look at the very beginnings of oath
keepers it's basically
sort of a left-leaning libertarian group
or central centrist libertarian there is
a broad spectrum a lot of democrats of
people yeah they're democrats that were
burnt out on the dnc which is kind of
repeating history
and uh because the libertarian movement
in the libertarian party was um better
organized and did better outreach in
nevada than anywhere else in the country
it's like one of the only places where
it was a real
legitimate thing
was nevada so we took and so he was
trying to take advantage of that is what
you're saying is is that is that
libertarian moderate type uh independent
kind of movement uh is how it started so
so you know obviously what year was this
that that he really started the oath
keepers officially do you remember 2008
beginning of 2009 he's
people so this is this is around the
time barack obama is elected
a lot of people thought it was because
of obama but he actually had two plans
laid out regardless of who got in office
sort of tailored one way or another what
was what was those two plans did did one
center around obama one did not or yeah
just to a different crowd playing to a
different crowd ultimately it was always
going to be republican leaning because
of the military right because you were
he was recruiting uh
active military and former military is
that right yes and so at first i mean
some of the missions they did at first
i mean are absolutely completely
opposite
of anything they came down to do later
the one of the first things that
happened was um there's a jose guerrero
jose the shooting of jose guerrero which
is a horrible horrible case and a
kind of a predecessor to
the black lives matter movement okay
just hispanic yeah um he was shot so
many times no knock raid his brother had
been um accused of killing drugs and
they came into his house and being um
a marine veteran he had a firearm in the
house unloaded he had a wife and baby
and he heard men in his house and so he
told his wife to hide and he tried to
crawl to the door with a rifle and they
saw him and shot him something like 70
times
so so how did the oath keepers come into
this story so they went in and they
raised money i guess for his wife i mean
they made a big deal about it half the
board of directors resigned because they
were police and they said you cannot
second-guess police in this situation
until all the facts so you're talking
you're talking about some of the members
of the oath keepers resigned because
they weren't they weren't in favor of of
doing this work yeah it was the first
major split
and at that point both keepers took i
think the correct road
and said you can't just this no not
great thing is getting people killed you
can't just do this you can't just you
know he's hispanic you can't just say no
one's no one's going to notice this
tara's door down and so i thought that
was a good call although i think it was
probably the last
good part where did it where did it
start to take a turn then i would say
well bundy ranch was ridiculously
i don't this this is around 2012 or 2013
yeah and i can't even remember if
ferguson or bundy ranch came first or
or last or what they ordered
together was 2015 bunny ranch would have
been uh 2014 bundy ranch 2014 yeah
numbering right yeah because it was they
were both after the 2012 election
yeah because they didn't play any any
kind of role in the romney obama race
yeah um
i just remember it's it's so bizarre
it's
water rights and
land lisa that has absolutely nothing to
get do i mean i guess if you were to say
okay well we were worried that the
government was going to waco them and
come in and kill the whole family that's
all we care about is the police behaving
themselves then the answer to that is to
live stream from the property right and
to explain to explain the bundy ranch
this is where the federal government was
going to take the leases away from the
bundy family on federal lands and they
were armed and waiting for federal
officers and basically kind of got into
a little bit of a scuffle there was no
shots fired or anything but there was a
little bit of a standoff between federal
agents and the bundy family and then
ultimately which there was two kind of
conflicts with him ultimately um but
what was the ferguson
what did the oath keepers have to do
with ferguson what exactly was their
mission there
i'm not really sure i mean if you look
it up you will see
and those were both 2014. i guess i just
looked it up okay yeah um yeah they were
so close to each other i i'm not sure
what oath keepers did in ferguson i mean
to hear him tell it they were invited
there by minority businesses um there
was a strip of businesses that were sort
of in the in the heart of the riot zone
um one two of them were um asian family
owned and one of them was owned
natalie's cakes and more on by a uh
african-american lady and one was some
white dude
so it was more for like protection then
is that that's what they said okay
allegedly what they said they were there
to do versus
um people that were they did the job
there were people that were on the
rooftops arm but didn't show anyone and
they uh threw burning stuff onto the
rooftops and they dunked them in buckets
of water because whenever there's any
kind of civil unrest people take an
opportunity to burn stuff so some of
those guys did on camera i think they
did the job they did the job they did
what they what they did what the
official oath keeper's
version but then there yeah but then
there were other things going on
and
during this an opportunity arose for
stuart to um
have oath keepers participate in um
you know open carry marches were a thing
then right everybody was doing it
and so um
[Music]
he met someone who was a liaison sort of
between black lives matter
and um
and sort of the militia movement and
they were organizing um an open
solidarity open carry march between
black lives matter and oath keepers and
the idea was a lot of black veterans in
the community
um
would basically hand out ars purchased
by oath keepers
so so was there ever so so you're saying
that that that oath keepers were trying
to recruit black lives matter members
into their range for a short time
and as soon as i heard the opportunity i
mean i had personally i had been in a
rough space because i had lost a baby
and i i sort of mentally checked out i
was sort of a rag doll for about a year
and a half and it was like i kind of
popped my head up for the first time in
a year and a half and like oh something
interesting you know if these are the
things that you believe and these are
your values
why wouldn't you do this march and so i
said stuart
you're going to do a solidarity march
with oh so sure we're going to do that
and it was like the most interesting it
was the first time i'd done anything
with those keepers i started posting
artwork
for it and oh this is great and then he
backed out of it and it makes me
question and the person who was
organizing it says she was a racist he
didn't want to do it and
i mean i don't know
so let me ask you did oath keepers
because this is this is a common theme
uh among some of the populists that that
oath keepers uh somehow are associated
with white nationalists or it's white
nationalism um there's this racist you
know maybe tense to the oath keepers
that some people want to want to put on
them was there ever a time where you
experienced that sort of thing with the
oath keepers or the membership or did it
take a turn at any point with it
um a lot of people it's been sort of a
hot issue really because a lot of people
who who focus on extremism talk about
this right and they get a lot of heat
for it when they say with keepers is not
a white supremacist organization though
later they did start sharing stages i
mean they started doing things that were
really hinky and i would definitely say
that there is a culture that i would i
would consider racist of this i call it
the idea of
you know or maybe it was you that said
it this is looking out at a stadium it
was you said that and seeing like white
faces and mom and apple pie and it's
sort of it's emotional and it's it's
sort of a racist world view right of you
know all these white chubby cheeks
but it is also important to point out
that it's not defending stuart i mean he
grew up in spanish speaking home
it's not defending him but it's it's
actually pointing out a tool he used and
there's a reason why
he was able to actively recruit from the
military and no one else has ever done
this no militia has been able to
actively recruit you know thousands of
active duty members and it's because he
followed you know the code of military
code of conduct down to the letter to
make sure he could never legally
be stopped
from it would be a first amendment issue
and so he made sure
that
there was no overt racism he had people
who volunteered full-time scouring the
internet looking for anyone
who were members seeing anything on any
of these racist forums and they were
kicked out and they were kicked out with
a huge paper trail to make sure it was
known why they were kicked out
and um but it i know people get a lot of
heat for some of they're not they're not
racist but it's a it's a tool he used
and it's important
when when did the oath keepers really
take on
was it 2016 during the campaign when
they really started to support donald
trump and because because to me
um some of the reports about stewart now
it seems like he was absolutely
um the way it seems is he was kind of
obsessed with trump and also this
delusion that trump had won or lost or
what whatever the
whatever side of the fence you want to
say on but but um that they could
overthrow the constitution and and make
sure that the votes weren't counted and
the mike pence thing i mean when when
go back to when that really started with
their obsession with trump and uh
he started out very critical of donald
trump there was a plan he would he was
never he was going to write a uh
extensive open letter to donald trump
and where he said they weren't he used
to say so this is in 2016 dakota this
isn't yeah
he's collected he was obsessed with fear
of hillary clinton getting elected
because he thought that if a democrat
was elected there would be political
cover for the fbi to go back
and prosecute people who had been
involved in bundy ranch
which happened during the mauhyur
standoff is that created cover for them
to even though the charges from out here
were thrown out because of the number of
informants they
used it as cover to go back and
prosecute people who had been involved
with bundy ranch while mao here was
dominating the news cycle
he was afraid of that happening he was
obsessed with it yet a vastly over
inflated view of his own importance was
like agonizing over whether
already going to washington dc
as a paramilitary force you ensure that
nothing disrupted trump's inauguration
and the counting of the votes in 2016.
that was already a thing that was in his
head it was agonizing over whether that
would be considered um
provocation or create opportunity for
the new world order to
start violence and then use as an excuse
to not let the election go ahead so what
you're telling me is that he was
thinking about what happened on january
6 long before donald trump started to
claim that he had that he had won and
which he had actually lost and that they
were going to do the fake electors and
the mike pence was going to you know
bring up
they were going to try to uh create a
disaster or a fake terrorist attack or a
false flag attack and just stop the 2016
transfer of power to donald trump is
obsessing over whether oathkeepers
taking action would prevent or
exacerbate or increase the
like increase the likelihood of the
shadowing new world order taking action
to stop donald trump from taking power
and that was the beginning of stuart
clinging to donald trump as his security
blanket to protect himself from
prosecution and that's where the loyalty
came in that was the beginning of him
switching from being highly critical of
trump on constitutional grounds
to being a die-hard loyalist simply for
his own personal protection and he knows
he knows
donald trump did not get elected yeah he
absolutely knows that he knows it's
[ __ ] so it's not him right so in his
mind it was a means to an end yeah and
it's legal cover he's using it now as
legal cover he's using it now to say
well we thought well i mean it's already
being noted that that could be possibly
an out that they believe they were doing
the legal thing and this is this is
something he he he's been laying this
he plans
when he wants to pull his stunt he plans
it out
you know for years it's the only thing
he puts actual work into is
sinister sinister plotting well you know
i read something on your website and it
sounds like he gets that from somebody
um if your website is correct i read i
read
i read on your prologue to your book
because you're writing a book called
oath keeper's wife and um in that in
your prologue there on the website which
we'll put the website up here so
everyone can go and read it for
themselves what you have written there
but it talks about his mother and his
mother you claim in on the website that
and you can tell me about it that and
maybe this is how he grew up and where
this came from but you claim that she
was kind of a scam artist a con a con
artist um so tell me a little bit about
like his mother in relation because you
said earlier that they didn't really get
along but he went to take care of her so
tell us tell us a little bit about
stuart and and set the stage for the
audience of of why he is why
the way he is well they had a difficult
relationship they also had a very creepy
relationship and made everybody around
them uncomfortable
um
what do you mean by that what do you
mean and this is this is the mother that
he hates too right doesn't he yeah he
loves and hates yeah okay um yeah just
odd she was very like uncomfortably
sexual around everyone and just odd
comments like oh i i raised my son to be
the kind of man that i would want and
just strangely jealous of him and uh
there's a there's a name for it almost
like emotional incest or is really
really uncomfortable well you know
there's someone else in you know i was
going to say very similar to so he talks
about his daughter in a certain way
that's kind of strange i mean i i don't
know who that could possibly be but you
know we'll we'll let uh the imaginations
happen exactly the same way stewart ran
the oath keeper directors like into a
shocking degree yeah i think that that
sounds familiar to me right right well
you give a word to it in your prologue
there um because you combined two two
words narcissist and sociopath what do
you call it
narco-pancreatic you call it a narco
path in your program
[Laughter]
um yeah i mean she was
she was a minister
she was very in the motivational
speaking she would you know just
multi-level marketing scams real estate
scams and sometimes they would work out
you know but like in her favor yeah
they were small kind of gains probably
right
well not that last one i think that last
one people went to prison in that last
one well the main investor uh fled to
thailand yeah he's in an expat bar with
all the other people uh dodging
extradition wow yeah wow
she was dying of breast cancer so she
they did not bother to prosecute her but
people who were much more involved than
she was got hard times
they just skipped over her because she
was dying
yeah so and then that motivational
speaking stuff i mean she would
it was she used it all the time she used
it in the family she hold church in our
living room people would show up and you
know whatever she was talking about was
usually aimed but you just kind of like
wait oh i hope it wasn't me you know and
then she's yelling
this is whole sermon based on something
that had happened in the week and why
she's right
so he so he got a lot of his attributes
from her it sounds like where he was
trying to rabble ralls and stuff like
that in these meetings and trying to
recruit um it sounds like he learned
recruiting from her
marketing marketing for sure yeah yeah
and sales pitch i mean that was such a
part i mean that was such a part of
their growing up it was almost like
this was dinnertime
you know family discussions like you
know son i saw you use notes at that
speech why would you use notes you know
that that
you know stops you from sounding
persuasive
right i mean this was the thing
he knew
i mean he would give self-defense
classes and people would cry
in self-defense classes because he knew
all the tricks all the emotional
partners he would hit every button he
would say oh you know you can't you
think you couldn't shoot someone to
defend yourself
well would you shoot someone to defend a
child well you're someone's child you're
important and people are crying oh i
love stewart you know and then
so because stewart stewart is not a dumb
person he's not a dumb person like he
knows what he's doing i mean he went to
yale law school he graduated from yale
law school correct yes so and and and he
had his law degree or is his law license
for some time
right so he's not he's not a stupid
person he knows what he's doing um and
and speaking of that knowing what he's
doing and like this this prepping and
planning
um i read somewhere and it has to do
with uh his detention and the judge
deciding his detention there was there
was talk about these tunnels um there
were some tunnels being dug
and there was also some pictures of
stuart in the tunnels now it was before
he has the patch on his eyes which i
also want to ask about
these so these tunnels are from the
pictures that were on the internet were
from a while ago they weren't actual
escape tunnels correct yeah those were
that was some i don't i actually don't
even know where they came from i think
it was some kind of training camp he
went to i think it was we had moved from
the house we'd dug the real tunnels out
and i think it was
part of it was him gathering information
on how to rebuild at the new place the
first ones had collapsed
um but escape tunnels
that that's you
yes so
so before before you start before you
start because
question by the fbi about these escape
tunnels um i talked to them briefly
about it but it was a little i mean
i've talked with them but we've sort of
agreed that man i probably have a
thousand hours of talking to do them i
get you know the trials this summer so
we've talked briefly but not in the
hours and hours it needs to be
i see
go ahead dakota just explain these
escape channels and why they're relevant
to his detention so it demonstrates um
what we in the household have been
calling
and i might have stolen this from
somebody's tweet and not remembered a
tunneling mindset
which is like those those photographs of
him like what he's
what he's hiding in in those photos is a
spider hole that's essentially the same
kind of
um hide from a manhunt shelter used by
saddam hussein so this is like a
tactical thing in the future
strategically
okay
very into hidden fighting positions
and
um concealed sniper positions and
his very focus on his escape tunnels
until the actual execution came along
so
the actual escape tunnels were meant to
be
much more extensive than they actually
were we kept pairing the project down
especially when stewart stopped helping
he was only around for the very
beginning when we had the rental
backhoes and then it was me and a
rotating cast of like
they're called yard people the weirdos
and subletters that we always had
living outs living outside of the house
which
was like one of those like pay for the
rent by digging the whole kind of thing
yeah i guess yeah
so these are members of the oath keepers
is that that are that are bullied and
hangers on and
boys and anyone who said stewart you're
wonderful yeah anybody
he would put him to work then so anyone
would build up the ego right yes that's
basically it is he was if he didn't burn
people out so quickly i think he really
just wants to be a cult leader with a
little compound but he burns people out
too quickly and he doesn't have the work
ethic to pull off being a cult leader
because that requires people in constant
contact with you
to buy that you're the messiah for long
enough that they become committed you
can't get past to get people to commit
stage like l ron hubbard
or like the heaven's gate guy did so
it ended up i
dug the escape thomas
and
like 15 years no i spent an entire
summer
with a pickaxe and a shovel out in this
awful soil that was well over half clay
um trying to chop through the ground and
where is it where is this where is this
location is this even trico montana okay
okay so this is not this is not at the
house that he that they raided in texas
oh this is not an 80 acre place right
and this trico montana
is odd enough little town that
this wasn't unremarkable yeah everybody
knew he was digging escape tunnels and
it was just like oh yeah well
know that's kind of thing
people just
do that out here
right
well back even by trigo standards
what do you escape from in montana i'm
not really sure what the uh
to idaho
so there was a uh junk car that was that
had the title had never been transferred
or anything so it had been handed off
through multiple people in cash sales
and barter i think were just being given
as a gift without the registration ever
being updated so it was like five steps
removed from whoever's name it actually
was in
and that was going to be pre-positioned
on a logging road
and so nothing nothing suspicious this
way no nothing yeah this is just a card
just sitting there right just regular
old stuff regular old unregistered
untraceable
totally legal right i mean who doesn't
who doesn't have an unregistered
you know uh untraceable escape car i
mean we all have one right
we have um permanent registration in
montana so it's it was still technically
registered to like five owners back
right at first glance
it's good to go
right right but but but it's but but the
intention is it not is it not to be
right
and that's what the judge used in part
of her decision to make sure that he was
detained
with with some of that information
of his past now which brings me to one
thing that everyone wants to know
because this is the story that everyone
wants to hear um stuart where's an eye
patch we've seen it in the in the uh
in the mug shots
and in the tunnel videos like we said
earlier the spider whole
uh tactical whole he did not have an eye
patch so there is a story going around
that he shot himself in the eye um i
don't know how that is what it is do you
guys know the story and can you tell us
the story of how stuart seemed to have
an eye patch okay this is three stories
there is the event
okay and the facts that happened
and there's also the story he told
there's which is mostly lie
there's
also
what i believe actually happened and it
took me 20 years to piece it together
and then
there's the second event which is why he
stopped wearing a prosthetic eye um i
guess i'll start with him shooting
himself in the face
okay yeah sure
start there start there please
so um he and i were dating um i was 18.
it was 1991 um we've been dating for a
few months and already
even though i had grown up you know
mormon household you know amanda's in
charge of everything i still thought
i don't know this guy's kind of
controlling you know he's not that nice
and i think i think i might be out of
here you know and i get this call
that there's been an accident
and he has shot himself in the eye and i
didn't know what the story was
and then the story that he gave was that
his mother had had a derringer in a
drawer
um
derringers for people that don't know
have no internal safeties they're like a
gun out of the old west that's the
technology of them
if you drop a glock it's not going to
fire the only handguns that fire when
you drop them are you know overly
tricked out colts and you know 45
guys just do ridiculous things or the
very cheap ones the very cheap ones
that's a very cheap one and um
so he dropped he he was giving it to a
friend of his the dairy he needed
correct the gerrymandering she's
bringing the daringer from his mother's
house
to the friend because he said he needed
a gun he couldn't buy a gun because he
was a felony
his friend was a convicted um crack
dealer and had done time for that this
is a friend from high school
and he said he was just bringing it to
him he's just bringing it to him
because he keeps getting in fight with
fights with gang members and now they're
targeting him and needs protection and
for people who don't know a derringer
that's going to be a very small
concealable pistol
it's why it's so simple
does it hold two shots maybe basically
it's just it's a sleeve gun in some
models
it's the one you see in the movies where
when they're playing the poker great
thing yeah yeah
so that is what that was and so he said
they stopped
and for people familiar with las vegas
this is basically downtown las vegas i
believe it was an on industrial street
every town's got an industrial street
they all look alike right
industrial and
mlk drivers it's the same kind of
neighborhood it's it's
it's closed down mechanic shops and
there's no reason for them to have been
there this guy lived in a downtown las
vegas they were traveling they stopped
to get a drink there's no air
conditioning in his car it's like 110
degrees he dropped the gun he heard
something which this makes no sense
timing wise by the way he said he heard
it drop and then he looked down and then
when it landed right this already it's a
lie and then shot him in the eye
this is
so that's the story
it shot him in the eye
the exactly the story that he tells yeah
so and it's a 22 so it's bouncy he was
with that front that part's true and it
rattled around his eye socket and it
came out it was just sitting
under the skin here and they removed it
the bullet was the bullet was yesterday
wow why they removed the the bullet his
friend drove into the hospital he's kind
of a funny guy and he's a crack dealer
he's nicer guys than stewardess
[Laughter]
he said he drove stuart's car they ran
into the emergency room the place was
full of cops and he threw his hands up
and said hey hey give me all the tickets
you want about five minutes and then
they immediately said 68 camaro oh yeah
we heard we had calls and so that was
the story
um
ah i have another version well you know
you know the version that's going around
that people are assuming is that he was
giving lessons on firearms right and and
then somehow he was an instructor or
something and then he had been a
firearms instructor later but at that
time that has nothing to do with the
gunshot in the this is when he was 25
years old people are assuming because
it's it's funny to say he was cheating
right
right right this was long before he ever
taught firearms he did work at a gun
store one day a week just so he could
shoot for free and get discount ammo so
he'd been wearing a prosthetic eye for
yeah
the atlantic i think did a pretty big
story on him and they said he shot his
93 and that was probably my fault
because i provided all the background
info on that story but i talked fast i
changed subjects really fast and i think
you know i went over there but you're
saying it was 1991
okay it's kind of what you're but uh the
atlantic story reported 93 but you're
thinking anyone yeah and it's something
i did and the thing that rings false for
me especially
knowing him
never really admits to anything without
downplaying it or building a cover story
with hashtags and the part that he's
admitting to
point blank at the beginning of talking
about how he shot his eye out
is he was illegally transferring an
unregistered firearm to a felony yes
right yeah he knew what he knew he was
yeah
yeah and they're they're in a shady part
of town too i mean this isn't like right
right you know this isn't like at the
olive garden this is in you know a
rundown part of
las vegas
so over the years
you're laughing
at the olive garden
over the years he told this story
and he always told it from beginning to
end like a robot
the facts never change you know when
something gets true
sometimes you can go down a different
road of the story you can give more
information like what were you where
were you why were you guys going that
way you know and you can add things to
it just by virtue of it's not just five
facts it's a full afternoon
was he unwilling to like so typically
when you tell a story people want to you
know probe and ask questions to kind of
find out more details like you know what
the hell that's crazy so it was he the
person that if you were to ever ask
questions he would just like stick to
he's like yes let me let me just finish
the story and then would continue down
the robotic kind of way that you stated
and it's not like stuart it's not how he
acts and like dakota said he's admitting
he's admitting a crime in the opening
line of it
right right yeah or believing anyone
else he shot himself in the face he
didn't blame anyone else for it so i
already know the uncharacteristic that's
not right i mean if you're gonna make up
a story try not to say that you're
committing a crime in the made-up story
right so now his friend was a convicted
crack dealer
continued to deal crack and um and pimp
for years after that
this is somebody he knew from high
school
later on i heard him mention multiple
times that his friend henry had asked
him to help run security for people who
owed him money that means drug deal
right
drug dealer people owe you money you
mean in front of the olive garden
right right he's like you need to be
muscle run the
door right and so
he mentioned that multiple times over
the years he also had a tendency when
he's scared
to hide weapons in the palm of his hand
to try to palm a weapon like this right
which is the perfect gun for a dinner or
like a dairy right absolutely and it's
unregistered like the cars it was
unregistered that's a continuing pattern
there yeah
it had been traded to his mother maybe
10 years prior by an old man who was
dead he's changed owners
there's no connection to stewart in this
gun so if he was going to run security
to drug deal this is the firearm he
would use if his friend said hey i need
to go collect some money so especially
especially if you're at close range
because this is a 22 it's a close-range
weapon
so i think he was running security for
his friend for a crack deal
i think he dropped the gun and shot
himself in the face and like how awkward
and i think
i just think only stewart could you know
run security for a drug deal in downtown
las vegas and still not look cool shoot
himself in the face with a deer
in the face
well right
so tell us about the eye patch how did i
mean how did we go from
stuart with a with a prosthetic eye all
these years to an eye patch is there a
story behind that you said this quick
version is um the eye patch is because
he quit cleaning and showering and he
quit taking cleaning his um prosthetic
eye he just left it in like it's like a
contract lens he left it in for like two
years instead of taking it out every
night and his eye socket got so infected
that the eye socket rough shirt oh and
pushed out the prosthetic had to be
moved removed by a specialist and then
the implant
that took the shape of where his eyeball
used to be pushed out and he was no
longer able to wear across that guy oh
so so he is forced to wear the eye patch
yes
because he wasn't cleaning in the way
his eye socket has now swollen out of
proportion and can no longer support a
prosthetic eye and he never went in for
the surgery to correct that and redo an
implant i see so he's forced to wear the
eye this is like wearing a contact lens
and just going you know what i'm just
going to leave this in for yeah
the humorous part about the eye patch to
me
is that
he was he was he was
they got him in texas um and there's
another guy from texas with the eye
patch dan crenshaw yeah yeah
with the eye patch and it just i just
i'm like this is so hilarious how in the
hell did this happen yeah i think that
crenshaw still stole stuart's look i
don't think he used to wear the eye
patch no he didn't no he didn't he
actually he actually said i think i
think he's done a couple interviews
where he's like the the actual
prosthetic eye doesn't look as tough as
the eye patch so he likes to wear that
you know what looks even tougher when
dan crenshaw makes an ad where he jumps
out of an airplane yeah it has to save
georgia yeah right right right right
that's really tough well you know the
other one is down in a wing suit to
punch through a black dude's windshield
because butler told him to
oh yeah
yeah he wants to be iron man so badly
right right well i i always i always in
my content when i'm talking about dan
crenshaw i say get a [ __ ] glass eye
would you please because because he he
literally he has one he's talked about
wearing it he just doesn't he chooses
yeah he can at least be the guy from
last action hero you know you get like
just any you can have right now right
smiley face whatever he wants he could
have right and the other quick thing
about the eye thing is it you know at 18
if i had been even 25 years old and this
had happened i just thought well
this is unfortunate that i was about to
break up with this guy
you know and now he's injured and now my
family is his family's calling mike i'm
all involved in the whole family and the
drama and they're giving my family
updates
so it just completely drew me in and at
the time at 18 it was or 19 by the time
it happened and
you know i just thought well i'm stuck
now and it really
it caused me to be i never would have i
would have so that's that's why we're
kind of here today yeah because he was
in front of the olive garden
possibly maybe not doing a drug deal
drop that dropped the weapon he was
supposed to use protection and shot
himself right in the eye um no if only
there'd been an actual olive garden well
you know yeah yeah that's true hey hey
you know we're just snowballing here we
don't know how far there was an olive
garden away i mean you can never tell
you know it is big
after the drug deal they went to the
olympics right it's possible once he got
patched up he went through that i mean
we're making him
don't forget about the hooker part
that's applebee's oh no no
so there's a hooker story from albums
well all i know is the henry was also a
pimp so i believe hooker's preferred oh
okay okay so so there might have been
hookers involved in this
deal okay after bundy ranch he really
went
completely nuts i mean he really just
anything what do you mean what do you
mean is this the narco what do you call
narco path is this part of this
everything you can imagine a homeless
guy talking to himself down the street
doing this is this was stewart after
bundy ranch and we don't know why so you
think it was like a mental break then
and i mean is it what it it's just even
criticized yeah after bundy like that
because he pulled out all of the oath
keepers forces contributing to security
when there were rumors of the department
of defense had authorized drone strikes
in case um shooting started which is
i think a little bit far-fetched but he
yanked all the oath keepers out of there
as soon as that
came down and presented again presented
a false version to oath hebrews members
which was that they'd agreed to pull
back and do perimeter security and get
their forces away from the central house
so they couldn't all get hit at once
and they were going to retreat out into
the desert to disperse targets and the
people at the main standoff where they'd
be where the bundy farm said to become a
compound we're like no they just up and
left
on a moment's notice and then people
almost shot each other people got into
fist fights and it was a nightmare and
people were highly critical of stewards
so now he's a militia man and a friday
cat yeah and he's he can't handle being
criticized as a militia general and it
destroyed his ego yeah so did it start
to destroy the oath keepers and then he
pulled back and then kind of went head
in again or i mean what well the cows
coming home saved oath keepers even
though he had no part in it he was
the cattle hotel for that the cattle
that have been seized by the government
as like collateral against what they
owed on the grazing fees because right
right i had to make sovereign citizen
arguments in court for like 10 years
running and had lost every case so they
owed tons of fees and fines at this
point and they a bunch of guys went and
herded the cattle back out of federal
custody
back to the back to the farm and nobody
shot them and that's where there are
people pointing rifles at federal agents
by an overpass right and that that's
that's the that's the famous pictures we
see where the guy the guy is in a sniper
position um pointing weapons which um is
a whole other uh you know probably an
hour and a half we could do his name
wasn't known until stuart um said his
full name international radio show outed
him on the air after the wow
was the guy in the sniper position was
he an oath keeper or stewart just knew
him from being there i think he joined
at the event yes is that right a lot of
crazy towns yeah he met him on site he
was already just there so he he was he
was he was there not only to do it do
his oath keeper thing but to recruit um
at the bundy ranches
so yeah so
was the bundy ranch attempted to be used
as like a symbol of like look what we
can accomplish and yeah
recruiting and media attention and
donations and branding until people
started getting arrested that was a
pretty good pr yeah not so great when
people start going to jail so so there's
there was a lot of oath keeper members
you know because i want to get to
january 6 but i want to kind of tick up
to it through the trump presidency and
how that came to be and and really the
2020 election what stewart had to do
with the 2020 election because i know uh
you know the oath keepers proud boys
there's a lot of these names of these
groups that get invoked into the
conversation when you're talking about
trump and the 2020 election obviously
proud boys during one of the debates um
donald trump the president at the time
told the proud boys to stand back and
stand by uh not the oath keepers at the
time now the proud boys are probably
more known as uh as at the time was more
of a domestic terrorist group because
they had a lot more ties to white
nationalism um where the oath keepers
were more of this recruiting military
members because i've actually heard
people who were being recruited by them
and when they went to some of the
meetings they were like these people are
right-wing nuts like they're they're
they're right-wing wackadoos and you
know they they claim to be military and
active duty and retired
but but leading up to january 6 because
that's where i want to get here because
that's where the
um the indictment is for the um the
conspiracy to commit sedition
do you guys have any clue into what
stewart's thought was
for january 6 and the lead up to that
and the 2020 election or were you guys
kind of out of the picture at that point
what what is the
what what's your knowledge of what his
was going through his mind during that
well
by then because we hadn't been except
for um
like
mandated visitation with the kids i have
had no contact with stewart and she
filed for divorce it's basically just a
big long one-sided text conversation in
my phone
and
but we
um a pretty good idea of how his mind
works so my take is
what was what was going through his head
leading up to january 6 is
absolute fear of going to prison over
bundy ranch
if we double down on this thing we stop
biden from taking power trump i will not
be indicted under a continued possibly
forever trump administration because
the old version of oath keepers would
have been demanding the execution of
michael flynn for saying that we should
suspend the constitution cancel the
election or saying we need a military
coup
like saying that we need michael flynn
saying we need to enforce martial law
enforcing martial law is deliberately on
the list of ten standing orders oath
keepers members will never obey
that it's in the brochures
there's no constitutional um
mechanism for martial law
it's going to be a tool that will be
used to usher in a dictatorship without
people realizing what it is and that's
why we will never comply with any orders
to enforce martial law on the states of
the people it's in all the speeches it's
in its own words he wrote it right so he
had he completely deviated from what he
had put in 180 degrees
so so so and you're saying this is out
of fear of him personally thinking that
he was going to be prosecuted and
indicted for things that happened at the
bundy ranch it's also an opportunity too
oh yes it is to be like you guys say the
king of the apocalypse so it's more of
like a cult leader because he was the
leader he felt like a cult leader
correct right yes
yes he did if he could have carried it
off he would have
basically created
not quite a religious cult around
himself but like
an apocalyptic cult of personality
it was a savior of america so how did he
go ahead gabe yeah i was gonna say do
you think january 6 for him because
obviously you said like you know when he
is planning these things like he may not
be able to prep you know food storage
uh in the basement but in terms of
preparing something for the future he
did a pretty good job for that and so in
this moment in time do you think january
6 was like he had a backup plan or it
was just like nope that's all he had in
it like that's the only cards he could
play
well i think they were gonna make for
the woods for sure after that i think
they were planning that when
some of those keepers got arrested i
think there's some evidence for that
coming out now yeah they were talking
about again the obsessions afterwards
the obsession with the viet cong tunnels
again which is a recurring obsession
with stuart there are people in the
telegram chat and the signal chat
talking about digging viet cong tunnels
on somebody's retreat property where
they were well above the water table and
had good tree cover
um but i think stewart personally burned
his bridges with everybody because he's
been itinerant and mostly couch surfing
since he was living with us
so i think he's burned his bridges with
anyone that would have a spot open in a
compound like he burned out all those
people where he could go that had a
bunker where he could go and hold up and
hole up so he just was continuing to
capture from support of the supporter
right so so what what house was he were
they raided in and near near in texas is
that is because there is there is a
person who has taken the reins of the
oath keepers um unofficially or
officially her name her name is kelly
sorio she's actually running for seat in
texas's house i believe uh state house
is what she's running for so she is
actually a a republican candidate for a
congressional seat in the state of texas
uh am i am i right by saying that that
that this is that the person who has
kind of i don't know if it's officially
unofficially
representing herself as acting president
of oath keepers okay so she kind of took
it on herself yes i think so now now is
are her and stewart romantically
involved yeah no okay yeah i had to bet
money i would say yeah she's publicly
denying it yeah i think they've been
living together since
probably right before
so this is her house that he was that
they were he was they found i mean it
seems like they're in a relationship but
it seems to be real i mean nobody can
put up i mean
just
only this is like could put up with
stewart for more than one year in a
while just the mess i mean you know i
just it's so frustrating but she he had
moved i think he had left and stayed
with someone i don't know whose house he
was arrested at
right i mean they have pictures of him
right
they were okay with really it was like
some random person he was running from
the house couchsurfing around you know
can you imagine but i think they were
oath keepers as far as i know i think
that's what i was told so i want to
circle back for a second because i find
it very interesting
that um you were saying that stewart was
writing in his own words like there was
no way that the oath keepers would have
anything to do
with um not only not only the big lie
but actually executing the eastman memo
which we all know now the eastman memo
was to
stall the electors and have uh this
alternative slate of electors so and i
mean that the crowd was chanting hang
mike pence there's a gallow gallows
outside the president united states was
basically saying if mike pence doesn't
do what we want him to do then he'll be
a bad guy and you know he's kind of
stoking this fear and stoking the mob
but what you're saying is
specifically
that stuart rhodes and the oath keepers
would have never done that unless there
was this flip so so
did how did stuart manage to take this
entire
um narrative on uh martial law like you
said michael flynn they they probably
would have disowned him and you know
shunned him aside
how how do you think stewart took the
oath keepers from that
um uh
that i i don't know i guess it's a bylaw
for the oath keepers um to the point to
where he's doing a total 180 and doing
exactly that how does he take that and
was the chapters broken up was the oath
keepers was there tension there do you
know because of that
a long time before and it was continuing
because he would burn through board of
directors members he would burn through
um state chapter leadership there was a
constant rotating cast both keywords
leadership because nobody could deal
with stuart because he would obsessively
bottleneck all work through himself
and then never do anything because he
was too lazy to almost as a point of
pride that it was too important to do
stuff so the organization was always so
dysfunctional was on the verge of
collapsing and barely make payroll
and everyone is trying to make it
functional and stewart is obstructing
everything and is always involved in
petty drama so people would resign and
then they would get new eager volunteers
to use for their labor to promote health
keepers and keep it running
and in this time especially from bundy
ranch onwards there had been a slow
decline from
the bright shining
libertarian
broad spectrum
nra aclu voltroning of
uh civil rights organizations on like a
libertarian right-ish side
great constitution i would also because
i would imagine that that steady decline
is you're getting a complete degradation
and quality of service members
to the oath keepers because you're like
well there's only so many people with
experience that could actually lead a
group and if i keep burning them
then it's only new people and there are
dozens of oath keepers created groups
that are just out there so they're not
actually associated with him but they're
called like oath keepers in some form
just in spite of stewart they made their
own yeah well so so it sounds like um
what you're describing because this is
uh
multi-level marketing the mll stuff kind
of
you know like like because you said his
mom did that like where they would
recruit new people and those new people
would have ambition and excitement
whereas the old
old members were burnt out and and
disgruntled and so they get new members
and it would be like this new
organization every couple years or
something um you know this it's this mlm
multi-level constant remakings i think
it's very easy for him to
turn it into a right
organization just because of the nature
of so many new people
the path it was the path of least
resistance for him to keep making money
and the path of least resistance took
him down the road
of gradually turning oath keepers into a
militia which also played instead of a
veterans and police and first responders
organization which also played into
his desire
like internal fantasy of being a
post-apocalyptic warlord and like savior
of america
in the case of a civil war so it was a
path of least resistance that played
well into his own
unquenchable lust for self-glorification
and his personal apocalypse fantasies
and as you start to go along that he
burns out highly competent people and we
start getting weirdos and like fake
veterans all the time yeah possibly
having to kick out yeah
so people who had claimed to be veterans
but it was
it was uh they didn't have the actual
valor um of a veteran
valor people and you couldn't tell
stewart anything dakota was constantly
like this guy's fake he would not hear
it he would go get matching he wouldn't
got matching tattoos with a famous
stolen valor guy i can't even remember
what he said that was a mouse that was
mouse frozen he claimed that he lost um
friends in combat when a helicopter was
shot oh he had this whole story people
cried yeah he was a really energetic
public speaker and they got they got
matching oath keepers um three percent
till valhalla skull tattoos on their
biceps and it turns out he'd never even
foreign deployed and he was involved in
a training accident so this is a real
bromance with a liar yeah yeah yeah he
had a series of flash in the pan
incredibly intense bromances where yeah
whoever he was talking about could do no
wrong even if you know it's very
familiar it sounds familiar did he have
did he have some sort of bromance and
maybe maybe the multi-level marketing
and this revolving door of do you do you
think a lot of this the trump movement
and the make america great again
movement um you know we've seen the
alt-right but they died very quickly
after charlottesville because that was
not very good for the brand of the right
vanguard america they just rebranded and
tried to subsume themselves more in
the rake in regular right-wing politics
instead of trying to take over as a loud
proud presence do you think that's part
of do you think that's part of the these
oath keepers becoming more trumpian
um as they were looking for recruits it
was easy to recruit people under this
guise of manga and make america great
again i think that just kind of happened
naturally as an outgrowth of where he
was taking it i think maybe he
saw an opportunity to grab energy i mean
he's a narcissist so that's what they do
right even small scale they just like
absorb energy from everybody i think he
did it in small and large scale because
as we did with ron paul movement right
he saw and then i think he saw a lot of
energy i think in the um
in the trump train
yeah and he thought well i'm gonna get
on that trump train you know you saw
alex jones was project that's his bestie
right he was going on that show every
two weeks for ten years
tell us about him and alex jones their
relationship they were like a married
couple i mean this is another bromance
that he had a serious bromance he would
get in fights with him and they wouldn't
talk for six months and
and then they would and then oh and then
he's in studio and i think he i think he
stayed on his couch when he first
separate i don't know and i don't know
he was in studio like everywhere else
like why is stuart always there for a
while he was almost alex jones's co-host
yeah he was on that show he filled in
for a bit yeah yeah
i was just i don't know it was very
strange i never did you ever meet alex
jones no i never i watched him on the
phone once talking to stuart
the series promised alex jones
the serious like living with him started
after we were yeah after yeah because he
was actually feuding with with him when
um when we made the break for it but um
they were going through a couple spat
yeah but i knew i i could tell i could
tell
by the way he was acting
even toward kid's visitation i knew he
had made up with alex jones that week
because all of a sudden he has some
interest in the kids which is you know
alex jones has been torturing his
ex-wife for you know a decade
over that and um
he started getting coaching yeah and all
of a sudden he's got all these talking
points on divorce and visitation oh my
god he's talking alex jones and then he
was on the show the next week in
like
the
my god but that didn't last because he
he doesn't care so you can't have two
ultra alpha males in the same room
that'll start seeing more wrestling
which
brings me back a little bit to uh proud
boys because i distinctly remember
the insane jealousy of proud boys
and his personal jealousy over gavin
again
before gavin mcinnes
um
tried it very hard to demonstrate that
he didn't hate gay people on a live
stream um he was much more the forefront
of proud boys and he is than he is now
and he would get so angry when gavin
mcinnes would get taught billy
i should be the last speaker he was
obsessed with it he was obsessed with
proud boys getting more news play than
oath keepers yeah right right so there
was a little bit of a feud there
jealousy you know being being coined a
phrase with the uh the alpha thing we we
call them alpha cucks yeah because um
there is only one alpha and you don't
have to say that you're an alpha you
don't have to you know project it you
just are the alpha so we we like to hear
on the podcast we like to call them the
alpha cucks we actually do a bonehead of
the week uh segment
where we crown the alpha cuck of the
week
i think alpha male is just a perfectly
acceptable shorthand because that's not
a thing
even in wolf packs that was probably
already well known
so anyone who calls himself an alpha
male is a self-aggrandizing douchebag
[Laughter]
doesn't keep up with the times well you
heard it here dakota says that
um confirms to us that uh alpha males
are sale
self-discriminating douchebags
never met someone who called himself an
alpha male who i would trust in any kind
of leadership capacity
so tell me a little bit about because
here's the reports and i know you guys
probably don't have inside information
but i want you to tell me if this sounds
like stewart because part of this
indictment is is that there was weapons
that were stored across the potomac
um
and that's part of this seditious
conspiracy charges where of course in in
the in the uh city limits of washington
dc
uh you cannot have you know firearms
um but that's why they were storing them
across the potomac or something and
that's where this other 10 or 11 members
i believe it's 10 members were indicted
at the same time as stewart they were
raided and arrested kind of at the same
time that day
um does that sound like something he was
in on
i knew as soon as the details of the
accusations came out i was like oh no
this is
even before there were video clips of
him saying we're gonna have a qrf staged
outside dc quick reaction force
i saw
the reports and the leaked uh signal
chats and it was like oh yes this
completely tracks this is exactly
something so you were watching you were
watching these chat boards then dakota
no i was not on this encrypted signal
chat that was after it was leaked to the
media i see it so so once you've seen
the reports and what did you call it
what did you call it again quick
reaction that's a military term it's the
terminology they used
was if uh things got so violent that
there was call for
an armed tactical team or an excuse to
bring it yeah their fingers crossed
okay so tell us about that a little bit
because because it sounds like you're
familiar with that vernacular you're
familiar with the plan
maybe it was uh part of some of the
prepping and things that they were doing
and being oath keepers themselves tell
us about that what what made you go yep
that sounds exactly right what about
that entire exit the entire execution of
it the
military
terminology all of it sounded exactly
like something
stuart would plan which was from the
stack
start the original plan i guess would
start a fight with uh antifa if because
they expect the protesters to show up as
bad as possible that chaos
gives cover
for trump or someone to invoke the
insurrection act and then once the
insurrection act is invoked oath keepers
can storm in armed and probably arrest
congress while they're there
in the noise or maybe a bunch of
congress members get killed so what
you're saying is so what you're saying
is you you're saying seeing from the
reports that you think the oath keepers
uh maybe stewart
in the planning here
that the idea was is to
uh have some violence um with antifa or
black lives matter whoever would be
there which none of those none of those
groups showed up and
maybe that was the reason why we don't
have the outcome that we're talking
about here um but their their their goal
was to
try to convince them to commit violence
so that way they could actually
institute the insurrection act like is
described in some of the plans like the
powerpoint that they did i call it the
cheeto dust kangaroo
that's what i call it here i call it the
cheeto dust kangaroo that the john
eastman plan um but that's what you're
saying that it sounds like to you that
that
they were using the draft
of the takeover yes um version version
one
of the takeover of the country yeah that
sounds exactly like something he would
do
but here's the thing
i personally don't believe that he would
that stuart would do that on his own i
think he had communication with somebody
risk adverse because this sounds weird
to people yeah because
being involved in an anti-government
group doing military training to fight
the civil war
sounds like a high degree of risk on its
own to most people but if you were
beginning i mean
the starting point of your baseline
psychology is i have to be the savior of
america in the coming collapse
then from that starting point which is
far removed from how regular people
think
from there relative to that stewart is
extremely risk averse that's why proud
boys kept getting top billing is because
oath keepers would hang back at like the
berkeley protest they were at the
forefront of all the street violence and
they can't maintain distance and a
degree of plausible deniability unless
he knew something like january like as
something as bad as what actually
happened was coming
right then unless he had insider
information then he wouldn't act on it
you know that's that's a good point the
insider information because there's also
been reports and i think the rolling
stone was the first report several
months ago um and me and gabe did
several we've done several bits about it
um uh uh
actually i think gabe did a video called
pardon blanket it's a commercial that we
that we uh air on the show but members
of congress have uh it's been reported
that they possibly were in
communications with maybe some of the
members that were maybe not oath keepers
but there were certain individuals that
were planning the january six i call it
the cheeto dust kangaroo for lack of a
better term um but again they were
helping plan but they were communicating
with members of congress which were
passing along information for pardons
that were promised uh for certain things
do you have do you have any
knowledge of this or do you think that
this is something that maybe is a deeper
conspiracy than just the sedition and
and does this conspiracy go well past uh
stewart and the 10 members that are
already charged with this seditious
conspiracy i don't think he ever would
have done this if he didn't think he had
cover to get away with it yeah if he
didn't think he had backup and that he
always hot dog in this no
well
if you want direct evidence of that
bears i believe i can't remember who the
third man is but you can find a picture
of stuart striding around dc
with um roger stone and i believe the
third was steve bannon in like a power
triangle formation at the last minute
roger stone's proud boy bodyguards were
replaced with oath keepers bodies that
was a strange switch
yeah so i think i think three i think
it's three of the members that were
arrested and indicted with stewart i
think three of them appear in uh photos
with roger stone outside the dc hotel
where they are right there's the video
of that i think is what it is yeah right
right but there's picture and video
evidence he and uh kelly sorel
i think and uh several proud boys
members meet up and have a conversation
in the parking lot on cctv footage
outside of dc on that day now so kelly
surreal is the
self-assuming self-assuming um uh leader
of the proud boys are that excuse me the
oath
self-styled acting president
um promoting that all over social media
probably trying to make a take over the
organization while stewart is in the
clinic oh oh i i looked at i looked at
her twitter page and let me tell you if
there's not white nationalism inside the
the oath keepers before there is now she
actually was retweeting the sign that
said i think white is beautiful or
something like that um from the
pennsylvania that there was a
pennsylvania billboard that was kind of
a blinking billboard and she retweeted
and i think she said yay good for
pennsylvania something of that nature
yeah final nail in the oath keepers
because stewart's personal ideology
demands that he'd be an anti-racist
warrior for america he really thinks
identity he really thinks like the aryan
nation has it out for him personally
because he's a deadly danger to them in
the kkk and everyone else because if
because he's uh he's out here for
america and that means all of us but
he's allowed that to completely degrade
so you're see you are saying that
stewart
may there are claims that he is a racist
but what you're saying is publicly he
absolutely tried to distance himself
from white nationalists
he
tried to
like his vision of oath keepers is at
least on the face of it
a vehemently entire racist organization
directly opposed to white nationalism
and look at look how that went that's
gone now yeah and right number at times
how did it go i like not just in front
of cameras but in like the rest to me
just in the car
i am the
most [ __ ] dangerous deadly threat to
white supremacists worldwide
wow so he was he was anti-white
supremacist now now i mean that's that's
part of this coupling with trump's
movement is it's hard to distance
yourself from groups like adam lopham
which uh we've seen reports of the nsa
saying that there were groups of
extremists wanting to um
damage power plants damaged power grids
some people are assuming that it's a
neo-nazi group called adam laflin that
possibly maybe this domestic terrorist
groups but it kind of the proud boys
adam laughing which is a neo-nazi group
uh the the oath keepers they're all kind
of merging in this maga trump world and
really becoming being known as all these
loosely it's the continuum it's
everybody trump created a big enough
tent that all these different groups can
be underneath it it's where you have a
spectrum of right wing that starts with
the kind of implicitly racist small r
racist
john burke society view of the world
like uh mom was talking about and then
at the far end you have a magical neil
pagan
white supremacists who think that uh we
the true chosen people with the right
hair colors came from a ufo
and
right trump's magic is that humanity
he's been trump's magic has been
compressing that spectrum down
to a uh hardened core of people who are
trying to use from the side trying to
use uh
mainstream republicans as a recruiting
pool and cover for their activities and
on this side
are willing to now align themselves with
white supremacists because it's better
than uh you'll you got to take any ally
you can and
from living under a communist
dictatorship
your nose align with the nazis
and right i don't i don't right
it's hard to not inject fascism but that
is exactly what when fascism takes hold
into a nation that is exactly what
happens is um they do give up and
compromise a lot of their views um to to
organize around the idea of one fascism
as opposed to many now they are breaking
uh mike flynn there was a picture on
twitter today of one of the events you
you said mike flynn earlier there
there was dozens of people at his event
in a stadium like it was in this big
stadium and there was dozens
of people ten missed people
dozens even yeah
he tried to give a sermon
um laced with good words for his q a
audience right we actually we actually
had heidi kuda we had heidi kuda on that
is uh a co-host with jim stewarson who
actually outed him on twitter about that
he put the two into stuart uh jim
stewart uh stewartson put the two things
together and heidi came on our podcast
and we actually got her take on that um
so i'm glad you brought that up because
because mike flynn is absolutely 100
doing what i think you're saying stewart
was doing is trying to protect his own
ass right he wanted to pardon he doesn't
want to go back to prison these people
aren't going to stop criming and i i'm
not talking about stewart specifically
but there are a lot of people who were
committing crime and corruption and
there was no end in sight once they got
into this uh this cycle of it and i
believe that's where a lot of this comes
from now i i do want to say we are
running time we really like to play
trivia but we're not going to have
enough time i want you guys to come back
at some point
please i really would love to pick your
brain on this malicious stuff at some
point and tasha please tell us where you
tell us the website tell us where we can
find you tell us tell us about um what
you're wanting to accomplish because i
know you're writing a book and some
other things so tell us i've been
talking much too much
[Laughter]
my blog is that girl tasha.com
i have a free chapter to my not finished
book well i mean and also it keeps
adding chapters to it so
this is a never ending process you might
have to have part one part two it's
gonna be like the militia um
i don't know it's gonna be like a ten
part
memoir no one's ever going to read it
i read almost the entirety of the
prologue
so that's how i knew a lot about what
was going on
me i'm trying to pay off my legal bills
and i've got an attorney now and just
trying to get divorced it's been like
for you know it'll be a lot harder for
him to slow down the divorce yeah i
would say i would say being in federal
detention he's not going to have much
say in in a divorce you know where he is
to get the signature and finalize this
although maybe he's got more time maybe
he can just sit there all day and write
up nonsense stuff to to clog the court
and keep me
i'm sure he has other legal cases to
worry about i hope so yeah i think i
think i think that's going to be on his
plate so so you have the blog you're on
twitter as well that underscore tasha so
we will put that uh somewhere on the
screen too so
that everyone can go the code is all
over twitter he just he just got dakota
v adams okay yeah so so dakota uh go
follow tasha and dakota and i want to
have both of you back on i really do
appreciate you coming on um and giving
us your story i promise next time we
will we'll try to make more time i just
had so many questions for you and i know
and i'm sure there's a ton more stories
as well oh right i'm sure there's just
like hundreds and hundreds of stories
that we can tell so next time we i
promise we will play trivia um but i
really appreciate you guys coming on
thank you very much thanks for having us
yes yes
yep come back anytime everyone audience
stick around we will be right back after
these messages
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
headlines
[Music]
under president joe biden the american
economy adds 467
000 new jobs in the month of january
thanks brandon
[Music]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
what an interview that was
what do you guys think
crazy crazy stuff
crazy
crazy stuff i think we're gonna do
bonehead of the week here gabe are you
ready for the uh
the bone end of the week
what do we got going let's uh yeah yeah
let's i'm just getting the video ready
but we can you can start this bad boy
yeah okay okay what do you think of the
interview while you're uh loading that
up ooh baby talk about jew c
g like like juice falling out of the eye
right right oh my god
i i even i uh i commented in the chat
there during the uh during the interview
i was like that prosthetic guy didn't
even want to be there
he was like
i'm out [ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm out of here i
like like they won't it that doesn't
want anything to do with with with
stuart at all
no he is uh uh that that yeah that oh my
god the
ever i mean they gave insight into a lot
of stuff but i look at him like oh boy
this is uh this is some stuff i had not
heard or read anywhere else right well
you know the big surprise to me was
how stuart was actually so
vehemently against having white
supremacists in the beginning you know
because like he was trying to attract uh
uh you know active duty and veterans to
the militia right which
which uh like like they said is not a
common thing like he's been the only one
to really do that and it seemed like
whether he's a racist or not he
understood very clearly that you
couldn't have this white nationalist
um you know stench hanging around and
attract police and all that because they
don't want to be associated with those
groups which now
since trump is the exact opposite right
like not only stewart rhodes but all
these groups
have really like well we might as well
go all in with this white nationalism
stuff right exactly i mean like you know
we said it before is
trump let the monster you know he let
the boogeyman out of the closet and now
it's like it's a heart it's a hard way
to go back right and uh
i look at it i'm like i don't know how
you how you put that thing back in like
we had worked so hard to kind of get to
a
a decent state in society with just a
lot of [ __ ] but like
donald trump definitely was like all
right so yeah we're uh
we're going to do this
we're just going to be shitty people you
know right and white supremacist so why
i mean i mean you know when he led the
country down a road that again and and
and dakota said it best because we got
to have him back on we really do because
you know he said he near you know trump
really narrowed the spectrum for these
people to really uh you know
um allow them to be
a part of a white nationalist movement
without like not even really knowing it
but it'd be like oh this is normal now
right like right like charlottesville
was
everyone's like oh no those are nazis
but then
you know normalizing it over time you
know both sides you know this kind of
[ __ ]
they finally work the spectrum down to
where like even even they're chanting
the let's go brandon nazis are chanting
this stuff in churches
like it's yeah oh separation is church
and state right yeah totally well i mean
you know you've got these people that
are holding a church of a place of
worship and using it as a political
uh
you know
moving around essentially
um
to
[Music]
to use it as an excuse to just [ __ ] on
um
a political candidate right right but
again like oh it's not vulgar it's not
bad like don't worry about it you know
it's like but this is this is the whole
problem that that that even stuart has
and they explained it where he has this
paranoia about the bundy ranch like they
get all these things worked into these
people's minds right right like this
this this delusion of what's real and
what's not and and obviously they
believe that uh stewart had this
delusion that if joe biden was elected
somehow he was gonna you know prosecute
him because of the bundy ranch uh you
know he would go to federal prison so so
the thing that he does is commit federal
crimes
that are going to put him in federal
prison i just i can't even i can't even
describe how they even got to this
situation
yeah it's it's just insane to be like
hey to yeah to get my
to get myself to keep myself out of jail
i gotta do something that will put
myself
right right right it's [ __ ]
ridiculous so um what a bunch of [ __ ]
boneheads speaking of boneheads why
don't we start the bonehead of the week
we're gonna switch here hey there we go
looky there we got the bonehead of the
week going let's start the let's start
the music and we'll go to bonehead of
the week
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to bonehead of the week
um
we had we had a lot of boneheads this
week as we do every weekend
it was definitely one of those things
that were like last minute like oh [ __ ]
who's gonna be who's the you know
dishonorable mention who's the alpha
cuck right right right well um we've
we've got some we've got some good
some good candidates and you guys went
to the poll let's let's look at the poll
here uh the poll was uh josh hawley of
course donald trump this is the first
time he's ever appeared yep this is the
first time he's made a little cameo in
here i mean we can't really let's take
this uh banner down there we go that way
we can see the whole thing uh and then
thomas massey i think thomas massey has
been on once before have we ever had
josh holly on the bonus no uh
josh pornhub holly has not been on the
show yet thomas massey was on the show
when he decided to say hey there was a
school shooting you know what the best
thing i should do is send out a postcard
a christmas family card
that asks santa for more ammo
he was following the footsteps of our
our idiot
um lauren bobert okay
well so what did he do this week because
i know i know he made a quote or quoted
something um but it was so weird
like a year ago right so he shared an
image and had a quote that ended up that
he said was one person but ended up
being uh a a uh
the neo-nazi and then on top of that the
image that was spread was actually so
there's a hand that's like pushing
people down right uh and it was actually
an image that was around uh originally
was made as uh a child labor like child
labor was pushing like unfair labor act
kind of thing
um so not only did he misquote the
person
i'm gonna say he did it intentionally
because
these guys aren't all idiots right uh
and then on top well easy and easy easy
on the not all these
i mean they're idiots i'm not saying all
of them are smart
some of them know what they're doing
mm-hmm and are intentionally doing it
under the guise of like
let's rile up the base and they're the
ones saying it so i'm just reiterating
that even though they're the same
white nationalism [ __ ] right right it's
just it's this slow walk to fascism that
they've
been that they've been doing and they've
been doing it for decades and just under
trump it's kind of like an overdrive you
know
but um so so we have we have the thomas
massey um i'm i'm not even going to go
there because we're we're we're we're 36
years ling to the side i mean just know
massey's a piece of [ __ ] that's all you
got to do tldr masterpiece [ __ ] there
you go
now senator josh holly i believe this is
the first time he showed up on bone of
the week yeah he's yeah ooh yes uh josh
hawley um
did you know that josh hawley and his
wife have a podcast and they talk about
their christian lives i was calling
your computer will get a virus okay go
over go over to spotify and give it
horrible reviews without watching it of
course yeah give it some horrible
[ __ ] reviews like negative six stars
or some [ __ ] um yeah go do that yeah
josh hawley is the center of my great
state missouri uh that [ __ ] he doesn't
even i'm so sorry did you know he didn't
even he doesn't live here
oh yeah i remember that yeah he doesn't
live there and then of course whenever
you know whenever republican does
something like hey you shouldn't do that
uh
people are like uh well show us where he
has to live there and it's like
what why are you why are you defending
someone that just has like a band in
your state he's living elsewhere but
you're totally okay with it i mean i
mean he grew up
i guess as a kid in missouri
and his his sister
lives in um the southwest part
you know what i'm going to start a
birther movement around josh hawley i
want to see i want to see the birth
certificate i want to see
hey i'm good with that i mean i think i
think we should that's a thing that we
should do
um
and you know i was kind of
disappointed that that josh howie made
the bonehead contestant list and the
reason why he did is because
um you know he's putin's puppy right you
know he was really you know
he's all in for putin you know he
definitely he definitely wants putin to
take ukraine and he wants biden to lose
this war against putin yeah but the
thing is josh hawley is trying to use
his excuse of supporting putin under
this whole like we shouldn't support
nato anymore excuse me and that's what
all of the republican base and his
followers are doing they're like oh yeah
well neo-liberalism you guys uh want to
support fascism
and it's like dude
homie is a fascist right trying to
overthrow the us government right right
like
well and and just speaking of fascists
josh hawley nazi i mean the whole i wish
we had the picture right yeah
yeah no i always i've always said about
that picture where he's pumping the fist
that [ __ ] he really needs to get his
arms straight and get his fingers out
like yeah yeah hitler would be really
disappointed in that [ __ ] alpha cuck
yeah you know he's got a copy of
mineconf in the in her
pocket absolutely absolutely well i mean
you know right next to his pocket
constitution right right you know what i
mean i mean every once in a while you're
out and about and you need some toilet
paper your pocket constitution to
republicans should work [ __ ]
fantastic exactly
so um so uh josh holly
you know obviously um he's definitely a
bonehead and an alpha cuck like i said i
wish i wish we would have uh had him
like
as alpha cuck of the week but we got
some other alpha cucks coming but you
got 30 percent of the vote believe it or
not again trump the child
josh
well they don't right right
i mean how could you but right but
but donald trump was out front the
entire time yeah i mean as soon as we
launched the poll it was like
right i mean right now again this is the
first time that the cheeto dust mobster
has ever appeared on the back of the
weekend and i actually like the picture
that you have um yeah you know it's i
always try to find the best photos of
people sometimes
this one i don't know somewhere on
google i googled it you know i i
don't
duck duck go gave you the the donald
trump
best man ever in the world and it gave
me this photo that's what it gave you
yeah you know well
goes on bias
it is i hear that's what that's what
they say people small tech baby small
tech
oh
so so what did what did the [ __ ] uh
king of the boneheads donald trump do
this week that we got him on uh you know
he said a lot of [ __ ] quiet part out
loud
he uh he tried to he was like you know
uh
he goes um
mike
it was the newsmax video uh interview uh
coupled with his statement
he basically was like listen guys we
should have overthrown
and overturned the election let's
overthrow the government he was
revealing you know the quiet part out
loud and uh of course his father's like
yeah totally it's great and then some
obviously anyone with the brains like
uh did he just say that because he i
think he just said that he just said it
right guys and that's why everyone's
like yo merrick garland hey you come
check it out he's admitting it you know
well i mean i mean you know and we
talked about this earlier in the week
when he released that statement
basically saying i wanted to overthrow
the government of the united states that
was the whole intention and mike pence
should have done that thing because he
should have and could have and would
have and it was worked
well you actually i sent it to you in a
dm i'm like have you seen this it was
like two minutes after it dropped yeah
and you're like how can i make this
funnier i'm like you can't it's not it's
like there's no parody it's not even a
thing that like like he would say
something and then what you would do is
like oh i tried to overthrow the united
states government and it wouldn't right
it wouldn't be it would you know
sometimes the original is the best type
of parody or satire right
i'm trying to find this uh this video
here of this [ __ ] bonehead talking
about um
when he's talking about pardoning people
because that was the other that was the
other thing that he said oh yeah he was
gonna pardon all of the uh how he feels
that the j6
uh
insurrectionist should be pardoned
um
so i don't know i'm kind of curious to
see how these people now respond to that
interview to be like oh oh oh you know
with the blind faith that he's going to
come back or he's going to be reinstated
or re-elected and then all of a sudden
he's going to pardon those people so
i mean they don't make a deal i think
it's looking pretty bad for them in
terms of uh
their sentencing whether it's like a
like a you know a felony or they're
actually going to serve prison time well
i mean he had the [ __ ] chance though
right like he had the chance to party he
had two weeks to do something about it
and then in that time he decided to keep
fighting this election and taking money
and you know fraud people and
i mean i mean right so i mean he had the
chance to do this yeah yeah if he really
cared about these these insurrectionists
j6 crowd and wasn't just [ __ ]
uh just like word service you know to
people um he would have done something
right because technically he could have
now everyone would be like what the [ __ ]
is going on this is insane why is he
pardoning these people but if he really
wanted to he had two weeks to sit down
at his desk take that big fat sharpie
and sign his name on that paper you know
i'm still looking for this uh this video
that we've got actually you know what uh
let's see
i'm trying to find the one where he's on
stage um talking about the
the
the pardons at the rally
because i believe i believe at the rally
he was inciting violence right like that
was the whole point which is also the
you know he's got a lawsuit against him
right now for that very
for that very thing
right
eric swalwell and a few others are
bringing suit against him for
january 6 for basically inciting
inciting violence in washington yeah
there's and she's got lawsuits all over
the place right right well um here's i
think here here maybe the
let's see
let's see if we can get this uh going
here
there we go so this is the this is the
video where he's talking at the rally
about the pardon how many people have
been asking me about it
if i run and if i win
if i run and if i win yeah i i like that
i like that if i run and if i if i'm not
in prison
just keep giving me money
for january 6 fairly we will treat them
fairly
and if it requires pardons we will give
them pardons because they are being
treated so
unfairly
and basically i mean in my view because
this is this is the [ __ ] he would talk
about his entire presidency right go
commit crimes you know he would say it
to border agents he would say it to all
these [ __ ] uh you know anyone inside
the administration he would even say it
that right like you know also i want to
know how they're being treated unfairly
they committed a crime they're in prison
if they're treated unfairly then let's
look at all the people who are
incarcerated for [ __ ] uh having an
ounce of weed or something right like
let's let's talk about people who are
actually untreated unfairly not the
people that decided to break the windows
vandalize smear [ __ ] on the wall
you know cause death uh and try to
overthrow the government like if you're
gonna compare
something here let's look at who's
actually being untreated unfairly right
now not these dumb [ __ ] who thought
that they could overthrow the government
by literally
punching their way through you know
doors and glass windows right well and
and again um
i i would
i would love to play tons of video and
there there is tons of video here on
this
but
he was even pissed off at lindsey graham
do you remember this during the
interview he was mad of course i think
has lindsay lindsay's made it on the
bonehead of the week hasn't he so far
i can't remember he was his photo was
oh yeah yeah he had a tongue in the out
of the mouth lipstick yeah yeah so so
lindsay was on at some point but yeah
but trump was really upset
um at lindsay yeah um
and the reason why is because lindsey
graham
uh basically because they were talking
about uh the scotus pick right is that
is that the situation
yeah that's it's basically every
republican out there right now is making
the same argument right oh how dare joe
biden say that he's going to elect a
a black female nominee right
but yeah it is one of those things i
mean even donald trump jr was on some
fox show the other day where he was
talking about lindsey graham he's like
oh he's great but he's a rhino and it's
like
you guys just don't like when you guys
don't agree you just [ __ ] on each other
in front of everyone else
well i mean that's that's how they do
now we have um we have uh not that not
to skip over him because i'll give him
his due here in a second we're 47
minutes in the hour so i want to i want
to move ahead here to uh the
dishonorable mention of courses
the constitutionalist herself right how
many how many boneheads has she actually
has she actually won like she's
she's a couple i think she's definitely
been dishonorable mentioned a couple
times like she's
she's consistent
right well i mean
i mean the definite definite definite
bonehead and a constant um
uh member of the bonehead of the week
probably um she could be like an alumnus
yeah
but um here here here we'll pull up the
reason why we put her on dishonorable
mention i think she'd retweeted there
she tweeted this stupid [ __ ] last night
and i'm gonna i'm gonna tell her her
[ __ ] tweet sucks here your tweet
sucks i love the fact so i made it i did
a tweet last night that yes i want to do
a quote
a quote tweet of it and uh
i said all right who's gonna tell or
who's gonna explain
you know amendments to representative
lauren bobert right right because
there's there's this argument that
people have it's like oh is the
constitution a living document or is it
an original document that is supposed to
be
you know static in its place
and people always try to you know
obviously some people on the supreme
court believe it's one way and some
people on the supreme court believe it's
another way but here's the thing
if
you know the constitution isn't ideal
it's an idea right and ideas change over
time if you really wanted it to be true
to the constitution we wouldn't have
many things that we have today right uh
like lauren bobert wouldn't be able to
vote that's just that's just a fact
right like that's well there is there is
this thing called the second uh
amendment that she talks about a lot
right
they love their first they love the
second oh well you're right that's well
they can only go that far and they don't
even know what those two say and really
this morning i tweeted
i tweeted excuse me i tweeted uh
wouldn't you like or who would like to
see us uh second grader explain the word
amendment uh to lauren
because she really she doesn't [ __ ]
get it she never gets it and sometimes i
think like her team's like how stupid
can you tweet this today so that you
trend and you end up on the tony
michael's podcast bonehead of the week
like how can we get on bonehead of the
week i really feel like she she really
tries her god damned to get on the
percent she and i don't even know if she
tries too hard she's like i just you
know it's like i woke up this way and
it's like
cool you [ __ ] idiot well you know
that happens uh we also in the last
couple weeks um we've been doing
um you coined the phrase
yeah alpha cuts so we've been doing
alpha cuck of the week
and we had someone who uh i i think they
went on sean hannity last night was the
uh
was the thing that that happened um but
uh um adam carolla
yeah
oh i spelled
we really we really tried to work you on
the show and get your name right but uh
you alpha cucked it you know what what
ends up happening is i couldn't find a
shitty photo of him so i misspelled his
name god damn it son of a [ __ ]
son of a [ __ ]
well i don't feel bad about it it
happened it happened yeah [ __ ] them all
right so um this is this is the reason
why
uh adam carol and i uh let's see i think
this is is this the video i just want to
double check here
uh yes this is this is the aoc video
he's talking about aoc he's on sean
hannity they were being [ __ ] racist
and sexist yeah yeah you know they had
to cuck it out here on the um
on the sean hannity's fox news let's
listen here's a quick thought experiment
if aoc
was fat and in her 60s would anyone
listen to another thing she ever said so
basically before he gets started here
because he really he not only says i
mean right there is enough to be on
alpha cuck of the week right right like
just that
he
he's like oh i've heard of this show and
they do the bonus of the week but i
wasn't a contestant i really need to get
alpha cuck
that would make me an official candidate
for the show i know well you know maybe
one of these days they'll like say that
live on aaron fox news oh that's going
to get me off a cook of the week yeah i
know yeah right if we could get people
to use the show as a as a bird
yeah
his argument here is is that women and
especially uh women of color
don't have enough brains that you know
if obviously if she's not cute and
pretty which aoc is a beautiful she's a
beautiful woman you know i don't think
anyone right but
the thing is i think most people like
what she has to say
not i mean nate probably a lot of people
like how she looks she's again she's a
gorgeous a gorgeous young woman
but
they listen to what she says because of
how she says it and the words that she
[ __ ] uses right it's not because she
looks pretty which she is by the way but
that's not the thing that's not what
matters here it's the fact that she can
actually
hold her own and state
the things in an intelligent way and
actually have fact behind it right right
and whether you agree with her or not
like yeah you know there are a lot of
things that i agree with aoc and there
are some things that i don't exactly
agree with her on like i'm not i'm not
there on some things but here's the
thing it's like most people look at her
as like this extreme radical or
something like that and it's really
funny how they're like they're like
pointing out how gorgeous she is right
right um and and and
that's the typical thing they'll do
they'll go with the
uh looks you mean when they're alpha
cucking is that what you mean right yeah
they are right they'll target the
appearance first before they touch
anything else oh well you know it
happens with these operators i don't
even know that we have to go any further
with his statements here but i'm going
to play just a bit because watch sean
hannity really kind of freaked out here
yeah oh boy you're going to step in that
one
oh boy you're going to get alpha [ __ ] of
the week
you're on the tony michael's podcast oh
my god you're getting get alpha cuck
exactly do you mean by that do you mean
is it because she's young and
what what
yes she's young she's vibrant she's
beautiful and everyone's like sean
hannity's like oh you [ __ ] what are
you what do you mean by that yeah and
you like how they like go back to they
go to all three like what do you mean by
that and they're like oh he's gonna
double down all right
let's let's and let's play the video of
her looking looking beautiful but saying
smart [ __ ] into a microphone we're not
gonna we're just gonna mute
but
her opinions are idiotic 95 of the time
which i mean you know well fair enough
if you don't like her ideas fair enough
but to act like she's just some [ __ ]
idiot and doesn't know
against someone and not go against the
actual ideas or statements right
yeah i mean
that's this is this is alpha cocking 101
right exactly
how do i get off on shooting on someone
else and we're going to make this at
this alpha cooking thing let's let's
listen here and i don't think if she was
a middle aged he doesn't think which is
is appropriate heavy but again woman
anyone would care what she had to say so
if she was he did not just say that
twice
right well i mean the same thing again
he has nothing to add to the actual
thing well how could he how could he add
anything to this conversation when he's
basically saying
when he's basically saying if you're a
woman as long as you're pretty people
will listen which is [ __ ] just
completely um alpha cucking in and of
itself and it only proves that these
[ __ ] boneheads are terrified
terrified not of women but beautiful
woman because like oh my god if you're
smart and you're good looking like
they're thinking if i'm in a this is
this whole eminem and sex isn't sexy
thing right this stuff i'm in a bar
and i see a very gorgeous woman and then
she can outsmart me how in the hell am i
going to manage
how the hell am i going to manage around
this person
how do i exist in a world of smart
intelligent funny good-looking
charismatic women who can [ __ ] hold
their own and march of their own beat
and then these you know white fragile
men who's like oh the first thing is to
check how they look right right right
well not attack how they look how attack
how they how they should look like smart
women smart women shouldn't be beautiful
right they should be
fat old and whatever middle age and
whatever right it's like oh we're just
going to dedicate women i don't
understand that like like adam carolla
is he's not even middle-aged anymore
like yeah
yeah he's you know he's getting there to
geriatric right right he's gotta have
the glasses on he's got the gray hair i
mean he wears glasses all the time
like every interview i see with him now
he's always wearing the glasses and then
it casts a shadow down where he looks
even older and creepier right right
he is old and creepy
speaking old and creepy
let's give our winner the cheeto dust
mobster grandpa poopy pants the orange
mussolini jesus let's give him his new
since he won this week let's give him
his dues
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
i wonder i wonder what goes i wonder
what goes in there that looks like it
looks like a holster or something
anyways
speaking of alpha cooks um maybe a
derringer goes in there well it could be
yeah
you know it couldn't call call back to
the interview if anyone had called me
now you know go watch the interview we
just did with uh with tasha and dakota
adams shout out on the bonehead of the
week for the interview yeah so
go to
at tony michael's pod we're gonna have
uh the poll up for this week we'll
probably get it over the weekend we'll
have plenty of boneheads over the
weekend to put on the pole so go follow
tony michael's pod you can you can vote
there and then we'll do bonehead of the
week in the second hour of the podcast
uh every friday and remember the podcast
starts every single weekday noon eastern
11 central for two hours right here on
youtube twitter twitch thanks thanks for
hanging for bonehead of the week hang
around right after the song we'll talk
more about the interview
[Music]
[Applause]
so so the interview was fantastic today
seamless transition there i gotta say i
know i'm getting i'm getting better i'm
getting better
i'm getting better at this yeah i'm
trying i'm trying you're doing great
yeah well you know
i i like the new banners and stuff we
got to get we got are we going to do
that for both end of the week yeah i'll
make some new banners yeah for the next
week and we'll have a new we need to
have it make that kid party look though
like maybe some balloons yeah i'll throw
some balloons a little different do a
little different yeah yeah we gotta we
gotta have some time yeah right wait you
know we like the bonehead of the week
the music
but the interview um we gotta have
everyone in the chat was really excited
about dakota
yeah um he he's super super smart he
knows a lot about this militia like he
said like he was the teenage sidekick of
stuart rhodes
yeah as he as as stewart was trying to
work his way and keep the oath keepers
together um developing it throughout the
years uh it would rise and fall rise and
fall obviously we know now how it came
to be that that's probably one of the
most surprising things of the interview
that i think people can draw from it is
like what happened on january 6 wasn't
the original mission back in 2008 like
that wasn't that wasn't the thought at
all like that's critical of trump but
realizing that trump was a means to an
end to protect himself against federal
crimes that he had committed in 2014
right like it's kind of crazy to think
like
you know the enemy of
you know my enemy is my friend in this
situation but that's kind of how he
looked at it he's like i don't want
hillary cause hillary's gonna come after
me with the fbi but if i do trump then
trump won't do it right
right um so
yeah well
i i i think i think this is the
the problem that we have in the country
right now is that like dakota said that
that spectrum is near he narrowed that
spectrum um i mean jesus we even see it
with like the coronavirus i mean i
remember back in 2020
when uh the the the lieutenant governor
of texas um came on the air and
basically said grandma let her die we
gotta get back to we gotta get back to
making money profit profit profit baby
and and they're still there like like i
think i think texas just
inched over like the 200 000 mark or
something or 80 000 right and i'm
remembering
right right real great real great
governor over there and now not only are
they having more and more codes yes but
you know this this storm event
left almost 100 000 people without power
um and they had a whole year to do
something about that they literally had
a year to prepare themselves with their
[ __ ] dumbass privatized grid which
last year i don't know if people know
this but last year they had to get a aid
from mexico right
right mexico wait wait mexico paid for
texas
yeah they were like oh we'll do you a
solid here well meanwhile that wall is
just rotting in some lots somewhere down
by the well try to explain to some of
these [ __ ] boneheads that texas used
to be mexico and that'll really [ __ ]
blow their minds it really it really um
we're in a situation in this country
where uh
this the normalizing of fascism and
white nationalism um is the problem that
we have and we have to stay pissed about
this we have to have strategic outrage
and and go vote in 2022 to put a stop to
this fascism and make sure that they
don't get what they want and that is to
become a fascist state that's what they
really want for our country um and and
we have to make sure
that we stay vigilant and i hope i hope
these six hours because before um
we shot the interview stuart hadn't done
the six hours of deposition um so i'd
like to bring dakota and even tasha back
on to talk about some of that deposition
and some of the news stories so
hopefully the next couple weeks we'll
have dakota back on maybe we'll have
tasha back on uh sometime this month to
give us updates of what they know what
they've heard um some of the things that
they've made news about because they
keep making news is
just because they know these things
about stuart rhodes and it gives insight
to the oath keepers and what their
motivations were so hopefully then go
follow at tony michael's pod you'll see
everything there and uh i want to thank
midas touch for really partnering with
us on this interview
i really did help make sure that
everyone got to see it um so so go uh to
midas touch and and retweet and spread
their the the broadcast around on their
tweets uh thank you to the mizellas
brothers uh bret ben and jordy for
helping us out with this interview it's
a big interview so we we want to thank
them as well hopefully we can maybe you
know have that banner up more often i
don't know maybe i don't know i'm just
throwing out ends that's thrown out
there myself might just it would be good
oh my gosh brothers yeah right
all right thank you very much and and
and and gabe on monday we will be back
what time what time noon eastern noon
eastern
what time nine pacific that's in yeah
nine percent these are ams people ams
right right right right so
it is lunch for some people it is
breakfast forever we're just getting out
of bed you know yeah well you know until
until uh until monday at noon eastern
surf's up [ __ ] and [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking